this is joe Matarese I got problems and
they need fixing
I look right all right you're gonna have
to go through hell worse than any
nightmare you have a dream if I can
change and you can change
you're listening to fixing Joe every
week I'm gonna bring my real life
problem for this podcast my friends my
listeners my guests my family they're
all gonna help me and trust me I needed
I got tons of problems I'm anxious I OCD
fadd I'm narcissistic I'm insecure I got
anger out the ass and all these things
come together to ruin my life all the
time I'm hoping the show can help you're
listening to fixing Joe hey everybody
how are ya welcome welcome to a new
fixing Joe thanks for checking it out
thanks for coming back if you're a
longtime listener we got a good show
going to be trying to keep it tight I've
had some long episodes the past three or
four right I try to start keeping chose
to more like an hour 15 max maybe our 20
max we got a great show today on the
podcast funny man can hilarious comedian
that I've known for many years Tom
Rhodes if you know Tom Rhodes he's
hilarious Tom Rhodes of God and then I
go way back he's livin out in California
now guys been touring the world doing
comedy for many many years now one of
the rare comedians that's from America
but performs [ __ ] everywhere I mean
this guy has been [ __ ] everywhere I
don't know why I'm cursing so much at
the top big fan of Tom Rhodes had a
sitcom years and years ago on NBC when
he was a long-haired like rock or
comedian was like a time were a lot of
us comedians had the long hair you know
and he was uh he was like that he was
like the king of the cool comedians and
he's always been like I don't know how
to explain him he's kind of like you
know he's like I don't know just a chill
dude and I was glad to get him on the
podcast and he gives me great advice on
on my issue and that is this anger
outbursts that's new if you've been
following me on twitter at the joe
Matarese
all of a sudden I'm wondering is it at a
role is at a role combining with coffee
I'm just like spazzing out over [ __ ] in
the last week I had about three blow-ups
one of them with the snowblower that I
have you know we got like [ __ ] how much
snow did we get in the past few days in
the we have a 26 inch snow storm I knew
it was comin I went out to home depot
and I bought a I bought a snowblower I
only spent 400 bucks but the cheapest
good Toro snowblower so I had to
snowblow like three times to knock out
the 26 inches that we had just every
eight every eight to nine inches I just
went out there and did the whole
property so I did it three times but
when I got the snowblower i spazzed out
trying to get oil into the snowblower I
didn't have a I didn't have a funnel and
I couldn't figure it out I just lost my
mind I don't want to explain the whole
thing cause you're gonna hear a lot of
it on today's podcast when I'm getting
advice from from some callers at the
beginning and also Tom Rhodes and i also
give Tom some advice about his life and
some of the things that he's gone
through since I've seen him which has
been a really long time so yeah so
that's what was going on I don't know if
it's the adderall i don't know if i need
to up the celexa to a higher milligrams
do i need to not drink coffee when i'm
on adderall what is it who knows we're
gonna figure it out on this podcast
right here at the top I want to go to
the phones and try to get some of the
regulars to give me some advice on this
issue ok so uh let's cut right to the
phones right now all right let's give
Carlo valente we all know Carl let's
give him a call see if he has any advice
see if he knows what the heck's going on
with my brain here thanks to skype
should be a sponsor of the fixing Joe
pilot is italia hey Joe Italian all I
see is a picture of Italy it looks
wonderful hey italia all right i think i
find out nice all right look at you an
Italian guy with like an era beard I
wasn't expecting that yeah I know
everyone hates actually my mom calls me
the Jew because because of my hair and
the beard that's the beauty you look
like you just got off of a desert island
or something well when I was at the
airport at what we went to Vegas with my
buddies this year cuz we all turned 40
um I was the only guy who got stopped at
all the airports look at you you might
have to lower your volume a hair I think
I'm echoing back a little bit yeah a
little bit of an echo how's that uh that
sounds good so so what do you got for me
what do you think all right think it's
going on ocean for you what happened
just before you blew up at your wife
with the oil on the snowblower thing
well I was in the garage and I was
trying to finagle it I'm still echoing
by the way I was in the garage still you
know finagling with trying to get this
foil into the little hole in the bottom
of the snowblower right I had this piece
of plastic and I kept curling it to try
to make a like a tube so I could stick
it in the hole and use it as a funnel
right and it wouldn't work and then I
was just fuming like I was like like I
was I was physically holding the yell
from coming out of my body so my
neighbors couldn't hear me because i
have like old neighbors on one side
they're in there like 80s and if they
hear some italian guy in there go his
garage yelling mother [ __ ]
and I haven't gotten like that in a very
long time and it felt like the old me I
went inside because I needed to get a
ladder from her to try to get up to this
higher level in my garage to grab a
shovel and it took like an extra second
for my son to answer the door and my
wife came to the door and I just went
yeah I just like yelled right in her
face I can't even articulate to you
exactly what words came out of my mouth
because she just she what she didn't do
anything wrong right now and it's coming
from a couple of days ago where I yelled
at her for some other thing that was
like nothing and she's like I could see
the look in her face like the old Joe is
back and it's something I didn't say at
the beginning of the podcast is that
there was a time when i tried riddlin
years and years and years ago probably
like 10 years ago when we didn't have
any kids and we were just dating and I
can remember screaming at her over the
phone when the writ was like the riddlin
and worn off and I just felt like out of
control with my anger and I had said
something to my wife like this
medication makes me really nasty when it
wears off and she goes you know I don't
mind it because you're so focused when
you're on it that I'll take you yelling
and I was like really and then I had
warned her this time I said you know I'm
trying this speech you know its speed
basically and I might I might get nasty
again and when it wears off and she goes
okay I'm all right and now she doesn't
she doesn't accept that as an answer
like she doesn't she like how she was
when we didn't have kids isn't how she
is now like now it's like no no go
you're not yelling at me like what the
hell you got it you got it maybe maybe
up your medication is what she said try
a higher milligram you've been on that
really low amount well it could be that
your body built up a tolerance to it and
it just okay so but the bat back to the
issue at hand here uh well III got I got
two theories on what it might be
obviously if you have coffee with the
adderall and
and I did my doctor stuff basically got
speed on top of speed but because
adderall contains two different types of
ingredients and with the coffee that on
top of it depending on how strong you
take a coffee and what it is it's both
going to agitate each other I don't
think it'll work together so based on
the fact that maybe you've been taking
it so long and your body could have
built up a tolerance to it and then you
got that coffee just agitating it I
think that could be it I think I could
be yet are there certain coffees that
have more caffeine than other ones like
just the shelf k cops that I'm buying
well yeah depending on what great here
we go I like my coffee Italian roast
which is pretty basically a medium roast
meats but some people drink it like a
light roast and that actually has more
caffeine than they know because it's
sitting in there at less amount of time
so they roast in the coffee so obviously
the darker the coffee you're gonna get a
little bit more bitter taste but less
caffeine it has so if you're doing
middle to light roast on coffee you're
getting more caffeine than a norm okay
and I could that could totally like a
totally screw with you when that be
hilarious if I went to a doctor and he
goes I have the solution I'm like what
is light roast you might want to go with
the blonde a blonde roast at starbucks
Biderman starbucks blonde yeah I do like
it must be an Italian thing I hate like
coffee I like I like even dark roast
okay it could be that it cuz I said that
to my wife she goes you need to do
something you two up to celexa I said
why don't I just try less or not no
coffee in the morning when I take the
celexa cuz i take it as soon as i wake
up not celexa I mean the adderall
adderall how long you been drinking
coffee was this new that you've been
back iconic well it's our I heard an old
episode of yours where you said you um I
think it was yours where you said just
started taking up coffee you've been
away from it for like five or something
years was that yours that your mug
I don't know I I know that I wasn't an
alcohol drinker when I was dating my
wife all the way up to that time I
wasn't an alcohol drinker and I am now
and I also wasn't a coffee drinker and I
am now so it's not like I stopped and
started I I may have stopped for like a
few months but I never stopped for five
years but okay definitely I'm not a guy
that grew up you know drinking coffee
it's like I didn't drink coffee till I
was like 40 no espresso was on the table
I think before I can even walk that
thing went that thing went down like
nothing like the one in the business are
you one of those Italians that has the
espresso maker in the kitchen and the oh
yeah I'm liking it that's what you got
to call it with an ugly Don accent I'm
mugging it I'm mug in it do you have
like a I know Italians do you have like
one of those Meat Cutters in your
basement to you know those do you do you
met homemade wine my uncle does to help
my uncle sometimes yeah well you know we
had the super the sodden in the in the
basement until my parents they just sold
the house but yeah over the winter you
got you got the sausage hanging from the
ceiling you're like ever hear that Brian
Regan bit where he would say the guys
would uh would would hit a Spanish
accent just for one word there we go
today the water the agua is 32 degrees
you just did it with us a Mossad I see
what's up as it was odd I love it all
right so you think maybe maybe I try
removing the coffee and then we talk
again next week and see what happens
yeah okay well thanks Carlo valente a
soup Assad I soopers out all right I
can't wait till I have a really Italian
issue you're my go-to sounds like a plan
good luck Joe alright man thanks thanks
[ __ ] Carlos classic love this guy all
right we'll just do one other call it
looks like I think that's all we're
gonna have today and I don't see our boy
our boy chrispy is in isn't getting bad
doesn't look like he's around Ron
[ __ ] win we all know Ron let's see
what he's got always sent me you got to
do the request first I love oh god is
this hilarious it's got like that was
the greatest picture ever Ron hey man
what's up how are you good look at you
with the headset look at you he sounded
like you're on the radio she's that how
you do your podcast no I don't have a
podcast I'm not a expiring podcaster oh
I thought everybody had one dude you
look you know you look like a young
Roberto Duran nomas um now it's funny I
mixed up I mixed up Carlo with a
different guy I thought Carlo had a had
a limo job he's like no I'm imac general
contractor see what you need is want to
get one of those like things of that the
FBI have of all the mobsters and
everything to say with all the detail
which guy is who yeah and you're because
I know you're the guy who lives in
Delaware who I was mixing you up with
fatso Brown cuz fatso Brown is the one
who who Gigi's known [ __ ] i'm a TD fatto
brown he's a Brit he did british guy yea
he's the british guy but I was uh me as
a podcast he has a podcast exactly so
what's your advice what do you think on
this situation well i would say i would
say are the outburst that you're having
are they are this situational is
something that's happening like every
day is there something that's like going
on are these just to as I heard actually
heard you on the de pollo podcast about
your situation with your wife did I
explain yeah what did I how did I come
across that when I was talking about
that that I sound like I was you know I
was brawling with her now man I I mean I
completely understand both your wife's
point of view and your point of view you
know I need I mean I could see why you
would explode on her and I could see why
she would be frustrated about you being
late and everything it's just a one of
those tense situations in the morning
where you're kind of like everything has
to be timed perfectly and she sees you
you know
trim your beard i discern some she's
thinking this is Joe again running late
and it's going to screw up everything
I'm forgetting that whole incident
because I yeah I'm just talking I was
talking about the isolated incident when
I yelled at her when I was trying to put
oil in the in the snow blower but are
you explain that one on I don't think
you explained that on Apollo Swan you
know that's about the snow blower um
that's when it was for completely no
reason like that time when she said
you're late like that I just yelled it's
funny how i know i should never yell
shut once you have kids you know you
don't yell shut up to anybody it's like
right if you if i ever say shut up to my
kid i know that i got to angry and I
feel bad after i say shot up which is
funny because back in the 70s when we
grew up like shut up was like not even a
bad thing if you right right our parents
said shut the [ __ ] up probably and right
and almost hit us but it is something
that's happening like every day or just
something that's only happened twice or
is it something you know that's that
room this is the main question because i
actually had you know I used adderall
before and I had a really bad experience
on it o yours what was your experience
well I got basically what would happen
is like first when I first took it for
my ADHD I you know worked great and then
after a while it would wear off real
fast and I was like you kind of
balancing it with something else at the
time i think was xanax or klonopin and
it was became like this balancing act
and the more and more the more I took at
her all the more you know faster wore
off and I would have to try to balance
it out and I became very agitated when
the adderall would wear off mm-hmm you
know and like in that time period
between balancing between taking
adderall and taking stuff balancing it
out and taking another adderall it
becomes like a real tough balancing act
and I think coming off adderall or when
it starts to lose its effect can make it
extremely agitated yeah that's what
that's what I think is happening and
then I listened to Craig Fitzsimmons
podcast I remember a few years ago he
talked a lot about being on this time
release adderall packed right yeah I
took I took that too now how does that
does that just it i want it is there
some sort of
version of a DD medication where is just
you're just on it and there's no comin
down because my doctor said no no like
they're not I take it not because that
was my experience clatter I was real bad
i mean like i became really dependent on
it i was like you know i might
milligrams kept on going up and up to
get the fact i was like i was a mess I
mean I was a real massive really yeah I
had a negative impact on my life not
work and everything how quickly did it
become a negative i would say probably
within its slow you know i mean you
don't really notice it it's kind of like
and i couldn't like tell you exact
period but it's probably like I would
say six month okay here i think i've
been on it about that about six months
to seven eight months right now and all
of a sudden this is a new thing where
I'm turning into that yet that outburst
version of myself but uh you know I was
on and I would like be up for days on it
was really yeah how would he be up for
like you know like I would never get any
sleep on it and like you know I was
really I was a messy and I mean I was
not I was not taking it the right way
you know you know was just like it
became addicted on a bit to it basically
yeah yeah Artie Lange is mentioned that
to me that he didn't didn't like the
idea of me being the narcotic and it's a
powerful narcotic it's not something you
know I'm not doubting that it can't help
people I'm didn't you know like my
experience with that that doesn't mean
it's not right for somebody else but
right now I take a you know
non-stimulant you can take there are non
fibula I know I know what do you take
strattera yeah how do you like I nailed
it nailed it in the first try oh alright
really wait listen it's like you know
when you go from adderall to strattera
it's like you know you're going from a
completely different universe it's like
you know you feel like it doesn't do
anything you know like with adderall you
feel like an immediate kind of effect
where era your it's going to take a
while to get into your system and really
I've had to I almost think of it it's
like strattera is probably like only a
barely minor part of how I treat my ADHD
the rest of it I treat through just
behavioral management techniques you
know I just have to do such things a
certain way and I have to force myself
to do that without you know medication
what are some of those things like
always having the schedule you know like
as far as because it's really easy for
me to kind of get distracted and and
start getting hyper focused on one thing
and I would have to always have like a
to-do list for the day I try to keep my
keep you know myself on a schedule every
day I it's hard for me sometimes to take
on big projects like and I get a little
overwhelmed so I'll start it i use like
a kitchen timer and i put like it on 20
minutes or put all my cell phone for 20
minutes i'll say i have to work on this
project for 20 minutes no matter what
and I got to do it right now and
eventually you kind of get engrossed in
it and then it's okay you know oh I mean
like I've like a bunch of other things I
do that I that I have to kind of stick
to or else I can like wasted a away
being distracting like having all those
ADHD symptoms come up so I've really got
to be disciplined disciplined every
seller well it's almost like therapy you
know it like it what you're saying
reminds me of some woman who gave me
your card once after a show she
basically was an a.d.d therapist she
what she thought she had ways to help
people with a DD or ADHD without taking
medication right to really try to manage
it you need somebody you know who's
hammering you over the head but it's
hard when you know there's here's a pill
that you know all that stuff she's
saying doesn't become so hard right
right well I you know and they adderall
work for me at first but it's a powerful
with the powerful thing math like here's
an extent even today like I on adderall
on the last three days I don't usually
get these but I got a I got I guess you
would call it a writing job basically
someone I know is doing these corporate
roasts and he's hiring writers to write
jokes for these corporations that he's
doing roasts for and basically there's
you know 13 people on this one that are
working for the company that we have to
write roast jokes for and he had them
fill out questionnaires so and there's
55 questions in these questionnaires and
I gotta write jokes off
I don't have to write a joke for every
single answer but I picked the ones that
come to me and write jokes okay and he's
like spend about an hour on each person
so that's 13 hours of work right there
okay and he's paying me an hourly fee so
I had about five of them done today and
my deadlines tomorrow yeah I went to
starbucks today I was like all right I'm
gonna knock about five of these out
right now I'm gonna work for five hours
in starbucks I'm ready as soon as I get
the starbucks I I write like two jokes
my phone rings right right it's this guy
who works for an advertising company
that has an a company that's interested
in advertising on my podcast and he
starts explaining to me his company I'm
like this couldn't come at a more
perfect time for me right now because
I'm on the fence what to do with my
podcast and this guy's he was like you
know a guru for this stuffy and he knew
so much and he was so interesting and I
learned so much did we talked for two
hours right and now i'm looking at my
clock i'm like my son's gonna be off the
bus and a half hour yeah yeah that's on
adderall I'm like what the [ __ ]
sometimes I think adderall might make me
worse cuz it gets me it gets me talking
I start talking very much did you ever
have that yeah Patti as hell yeah
becomes like I well I would you know
start cleaning the garage or something
like that I'll be in my office and I'd
be like doing everything everything but
what I was really needed to do and
that's all my meds I thought that man's
medicos to help they don't they don't
sometimes you got to manage it on top of
it I guess yeah well you got it you got
to be careful man you really I mean you
like that unfortunately the doctor i had
was kind of a you know he was too easy
to manipulate and stuff like to say you
know can i hire the dosage or or
anything you really have to have
somebody I think have that check and
balance for you well now that nowadays
they won't just hire it like it's so
regulated like I had said to the guy can
we do something here and you know what
he'd ended up doing instead of giving me
you know I wanted to try to do some
where I don't have to remember to take a
second pill can ya can you just give me
a higher dose bulova what he ended up
doing he goes you know what I can do he
goes take the 10 in the morning and then
i'm going to give you 20 so you'll have
i can give you a whole month's worth
of the tens and now you have a whole
month's worth I want easy go split the
20s in half and now you can take them
three times during the day because I was
making fun of how I'm a comedian at
night how am I you know in the batter or
hours all weird yeah my eye and then
then dude I'm running into drinking
alcohol at night to try to fall asleep
yeah not good well I had a pride a big
problem going to sleep with adderall you
know like it was because I would all be
like you I you know I'd be working
during the evening and I'd be like oh
man I got to get this done take a little
bit adderall and then I'll son and I'm
you know i'll go up at 5am just staring
at ceiling or you know or I don't know
would drive you insane I mean it says
it's my off and I the positive is is my
garage looks on me is so clean right now
you can eat my garage right but some of
the stuff you talked about just being
agitated I relate to that as far as just
you know that adderall once it wears
down a little bit you know and start
you're starting to go down it can be
really be educated so like that's why I
asked is it are the use of situations or
exist is this like something that's
happening regularly where you get start
getting agitated let's say you take it
at 9am or 8am or whatever you start
getting agitated every day at 1015-1030
one starts wearing off and you know like
if it's some regular thing or is it just
like a situation that happened it was a
situation like that's why it scared me
because it's just I found myself yelling
at the of the snowblower and then when I
calm down I realized why am I getting
mad all i have to do is lift the
snowblower and put it on an angle and i
can pour oil right into it i'm being i
just spazzed out for no my liking I can
completely understand that because you
bought a snowblower yeah I mean you
spend a bunch of money you're ready to
do it and like if you can't work it
that's got to be the most i mean i think
i would flip out like off the medication
on the mat whatever you know that would
be something what that would really try
me not like I deal with that with all
these stupid like weed whackers and sit
like that you know there's always
something that's a problem with them no
but I come from a long line of nice guys
that snap like my dad is my dad
we disguise ever but he would he would
have those isolated blow ups and my
brother does too he right he loot my
brother probably worse than me um he's
kind of got it under control now but
yeah he used to just [ __ ] yeah seeing
him snap it his kids or something you're
like whoa right all right well it's in
our it's in our genes definitely so all
right well maybe a you know okay i'm
gonna try pulling the coffee off of it a
little bit at first and then who knows
maybe i switched to the non-stimulant
version see what that yeah the big
difference man you know like there's
going to be it's like to get off at all
it's not it's especially if you've been
on it for a while it's not like an easy
thing it's not a while Lisa wasn't for
me out to that you know I mean maybe
these for some people but for me it was
like I could not just a cold turkey get
off it it was it was something that
would be a major blow to my system as
far as just waking up and taking that
outer on getting that initial boost yeah
wakes you right up you could get you to
sleep for four hours you got adderall
you felt like you didn't you felt like
you had a full night's sleep all right
I'm great four hours let's do it i could
fly an airplane right now right all
right Ron well thank you man thank you
yeah I'm just gonna have two of you guys
this week it's a kind of the way I'm
gonna do the the podcasts I mean those
surveys really told me a lot okay man
cool and it looks like i'm gonna try to
mix the caller's with the guests so we
got um we got it right I got a guest
coming up who I already pre recorded and
he he gives some great advice and I give
him some great advice on stuff this guy
Tom Rhodes I don't know if you know I'm
really funny comic do you ever hear him
uh no haven't heard of them look look
him up all right yeah he had his own
sitcom years ago used to have really
long hair and he was like this rock star
comedian yet he has like short hair now
and it's a really interesting funny guy
um so did you I was going to ask it did
you and Apollo noted eating at Apollo
had a audition for the Kevin James to
come like he had gone to a Kevin James
all day said he read forward to I don't
know if it ain't partner Holly but he
was sure often he's just talking about
it on its podcast I know you got I just
listened to you guys together so I
I thought was interesting I didn't make
us fall I would have been pardoned know
that did he did he didn't say on his
podcast like he was pissed cuz he didn't
do well or something like that now he
didn't say that even say anything like
that he would never be that honest now
but it was fun it was hilarious like
that Twitter mix-up you guys had as far
as you sent like putting out something
about a comedian scanned him get all
fired up he thought I was talking about
him that Sanders yeah all right dude I
buddy thanks for being a fan thanks for
the ico and thank you buddy thanks for
trying to fix me Garcia bye bye all
right there he was Ron in person you got
to see him folks looks like a young
Roberto Duran nomas Ron Poliquin
obviously a nick de pollo fan and
listens to my podcast too and we have a
great guest coming up I want to go to
him and don't forget februari 13th go to
the ritz the Ritz theater in haddon
township new jersey i'm doing a big show
down there go to joe Matarese calm and
buy some tickets there's a few left okay
it's a saturday before valentine's day
if you haven't found something you want
to do with you lady go take her to see
me on februari 13th in South Jersey if
you live far from there get a hotel stay
overnight support me I'd appreciate that
or make a donation to the podcast that'd
be nice to get some free merch okay
everybody we'll be right back with the
very funny Tom Rhodes
and they and there's like a fancy white
bookshelf behind you very decide
everything in storage for 10 years and
just traveled the world so the main
thing I had in storage was my massive
book collection holy [ __ ] nice it's it's
funny it's getting to the point where we
all start to know each other a stand-up
comedians yeah not from hanging out and
talking from hearing you on somebody
else's podcast oh yeah yeah you're right
actually you're right i hears guy guys I
i know i love and and I've known for
years it's not like wow I never knew
that about them yeah I mean you you and
I go way back and I I think i'm with you
were you on Maron's podcast talking
about threatening i travel in the world
and not having a house really just going
from country to country to city to city
right was the errands yeah and a few
others and a few others and now I are
you like are you not traveling anymore
as much are you more like in us in a
spot now you live somewhere now yeah I'm
still traveling but I um instead of
every week going to a different city um
I'm doing like one or two weeks a month
like a normal American headliner you
know um but you and I met I mid 90s I'm
guessing and then I lived in New York 98
99 okay the Amsterdam for five years
ranks and then I and I threw everything
into storage when I went to Amsterdam
and then I'm after amsterdam i lived in
LA for two years and I was never here
and I was paying rent on a place I
wasn't crazy about so I got rid of all
my furniture I gave it to like comedians
who I needed you I knew needed stuff
right this guy this guy needs a coffee
table this guy needs a TV so I really
reduced it to like my vinyl record
collection my bookshelf my book
collection and like family photos and
you know personal [ __ ] right
and then for 10 years I just traveled
the world like last month last year I
did five months in europe a month in
asia the year before that i did a month
in australia a month in new zealand and
then six months of the year just you
know relentlessly hitting all over the
United States you know well Jesus I mean
it's funny on and I hear when I'm
interviewing different guys I'm like oh
should have had him on this episode like
I can remember like I don't know maybe
like 20 episodes ago talking about this
exact subject which was oh I'm in a
career where I can go too crazy strange
places then you could never go to and
only recently have I went to a couple of
these places and I'm always hearing
these comedians I might it might have
been when I had Maz Jobrani on my
podcast and he was telling me how much
they love American comedy in like
Denmark or you know the Scandinavian
countries and I was and I think it was
right before i was going to israel to do
comedy for 10 days and I had an amazing
experience in Israel performing and that
times it gets to the point where you
come back to America and you're like oh
god we suck we're it were tear we're
we're not nice you know and you got you
you've gone everywhere and how did you
how did you transition into that how did
that happen well you know i was living
in new york 98 99 and I had a sitcom on
NBC 96 97 uh-huh for one year I remember
that that was the night you were like a
teacher with long hair yeah I was like
dead poet society I was like the rebel
teacher um but uh there wouldn't give me
any jokes the kids got all the jokes and
I was like the straight men on my own
show it was kind of frustrating you know
but uh I had so why should back up I
lived in New York when I was 20 years
old for one year like a dog in
Washington Heights
uh that's where my wife works okay and I
swore if I ever had any money I live in
New York with style so when the sitcom
finished I got a rock star apartment in
the wall street area and i looked at
that money as like my NBC artist grant
so aside from pissing away a lot of that
money on Wall Street rent right I
started to make trips to London Greg
Proops and rich hall are good friends of
mine both of them were over there doing
that scene a lot and they thought that I
would do well in London so I started
making systematic trips to London and
doing guest sets around town at the
peripheral clubs until i felt like i had
my sea legs and could go hit the the
comedy store and the best clubs in
London see that's smart I did the
actually the reverse thing my first time
performing an abroad was in London but I
had got booked to do this TV show at The
Comedy Store which was idiotic that I
had never been I didn't never been out
of the United States now I'm like you
said doing comedy are probably the best
place there and and I don't have any
practice sets that I was doing anywhere
else that's love in Europe I know I
thought I bombed my ass off you should
have gone over a week before and done
some guests sets around town stupid I
had no idea I was thinking oh my stuff
will work they speak English so stupid
they dude they almost food me as I was
walking up this what could go wrong yeah
and I they almost booed me it was when
george bush was president that and they
announced in my intro that i was
American you know that they had a you
know they had comics from all different
countries and I was representing America
and it was tough during the bush years
and i was living in amsterdam and i was
playing in London a lot and a lot of
those English comedians loved doing that
they would just in the in the intro all
they had to say was your next comedian
is from America and like the day they
have to insinuate anything just that
tone in the audience blue
ooh so like already year against the
ropes you know yeah I she I should have
called Tom Rowland's up and says hey I'm
going over there what should i do but so
I got him with London and then that led
to gigs all over Europe in Asia
Australia now there's a lot of American
comedians doing these international
tours but back then it was uh it was all
primarily booked out of London so London
was the key to all the international
travel for me and the other thing that I
noticed in London was the comedian's
there it was almost like Boston in the
in the 80s where he would always hear
these great comedians are in Boston and
they never have to leave Boston and they
just because of that because they could
make a good living in boston they never
branched out and never became these big
stars and london i noticed when i went
there is they paid like twice twice as
much as New York City so there was like
there was these comics in London that
could make a pretty decent living being
comedians and never have to leave be
like that little I guess london area
right um and if you set up like three or
four sets in the night in London uh
you've got this big wad of cash in your
pocket it's really thrilling you know I
remember uh and you know geographically
England is so small these comedians once
they get a television exposure they can
set up these theater tours around
England and at any point maybe not
Liverpool and Scotland but almost from
any point in England where they perform
they can drive home and sleep in their
own bed in London that night yeah yeah
and I I was jealous of that I remember I
had OA even that's before I was married
and before I had kids and I can remember
thinking maybe I should move over here
because I don't like traveling so much I
used to be really afraid of flying and
when I would get yeah and i would get
depressed on the road like i used to
literally like freaked out by saturday
night like
I'd have to like give myself a pep talk
to try to get that feeling of I want to
go on stage I don't it's weird you don't
listen to my podcast but like the whole
fixing Joe thing is like a lot of
different things that I try to fix on
each episode or your its best when it's
one specific thing and then I like my
guest to kind of share a struggle as
with me that I can help them with as I'm
interviewing you kind of about your life
so we kind of know where you're going
but like what are we fixing today well
um well I mean to end what we were
talking about there though like um yeah
like I i would have to give myself a pep
talk and then i started taking
medication about five or six years ago
I'm just catching you up so you know
where I'm at cool I take an
antidepressant called celexa been on it
for about five years maybe longer six or
seven and it really helped me and I
enjoy doing comedy more and I used to
blow up I don't know if you knew me back
in the days when I would get really
angry on stage if they weren't with me I
couldn't handle it oh yeah I always
thought that was entertaining though
comics do like it nothing like a guy
personal meltdown to really think other
comedians laughs and you're one of those
guys that brought relaxation to it like
you have that West Coast pneus like hey
whatever man just you just have that I
don't know where you grew up that you
have that worth ah my i was born in
washington DC my family's off from DC
and we moved to Florida when I was 12 so
I grew up in or in the orlando area and
that's where i started doing comedy
which is really weird because people
associate me with being mr.
international or whatever and and you're
from floor but but yeah I actually I
really love Orlando I think it's a
beautiful place to grow so do i I turn
your microphone volume down a little or
your computer volume a little because
i'm getting a little bit of echo back
when i talk i don't know if i don't know
if it's i don't know if it's your
microphone as much as your
you're listening to me lower the volume
a little bit on your computer get one or
two notches you got has that still hear
me yeah okay yeah and that that's where
traveling internationally comes up once
i got rid of that anxiety that used to
be in me that would make me get angry on
stage and make me afraid on an airplane
once that went away like if it started
with xanax i would take that on an
airplane and that would chill me out but
then when i would get to the gig my
brain was messed up and I couldn't
remember my material cuz you know back
in the day when you were younger you'd
fly to these cities you got to perform
that night you're not flying the night
before the gig you're flying the day of
the gig and yet you just flew four and a
half hours and you took xanax so you can
relax and I'm standing on stage just
bombing I would do so bad on the
Thursday nights because that my brain
from the xanax was bad and then I
started taking an SSRI they call it
celexa and a whole new me started coming
in and then I was like [ __ ] I remember
the first long flight was Hawaii I
performed in Hawaii and took a 10-hour
flight and I was like that wasn't bad
and ooh these now and then I went to
Israel like I said and had an amazing
experience and then I was like well
where else can I go to do that real men
I've never done that gig for avi and
I've asked him a few times I don't know
you know what yeah that's a gig that
I've actively pursued I would love to go
to Israel oh you would love it out of
the audiences they're so good you it's
one of those I'm sure this is this is
what's cool about going abroad and
you've mastered it and you probably know
but if you're going to a place that you
haven't been to it probably takes you
one or two shows right that's what it
was in Israel you're like oh like
because you go to certain cities that
were overly religious where you know
they're all you know you're there very
Orthodox and if you just did it I mean
that this is how tight they would be
with dirtiness like Brian Kylie you know
Brian Kylie yeah he's a writer for Conan
and he's a he
started in boston and he lives in LA now
and he's as clean as they come I mean
squeaky and like if he had a joke that
was like super not dirty and you could
like feel he said he could feel the
crowd like ooh you know like ooh did you
just you just talked about sex like so I
heard you have to be really really
squeaky clean on it which is remarkable
to me because like oh you can handle you
know um you know buses being blown up
and terrorists act but you can't you
know a mild penis reference is gonna
topple your apple cart I don't know yeah
it's true and you know and you got the
women the word Bible there's nothing but
[ __ ] going on to that it's one of the
most filthy pornographic books ever
written something David for a minute but
it is one of those gigs all over the
place it is one of those gigs though
that like one city will be overly
religious and then the next one isn't so
it's like you gotta keep adjusting ira
even like Kent Canada the first time I
went to Montreal I'm like doing a joke
about going to a community college
growing up and they're staring at me and
then I realized oh they don't have a
community college here they don't call
it that they don't even have a low-level
university they have either no college
or good college no [ __ ] college and you
know and another thing I learned from
performing abroad is oh you can just ask
questions when you don't know and you
can make that funny you don't have to
get mad that they don't know what you're
talking about well for me the exciting
thing is that adjustment yeah when you
go to a different country and like so
like what's funny in Ireland isn't funny
in England and Holland and France so
like for me going every week to a
different city or a different country
that adjustment you have to make on
stage it's terrifying and yet like
really exhilarating like that's a high
that I really got off on on all this
international travel yeah that's with
you and then like what you lose in
references you always gain in
observations almost everywhere love
when a foreigner gives you their
observations on something that they you
observed while you were there yeah and
like and like you go oh wow it's funny
I've lived here my whole life I never
thought of it that way you know yes
that's one thing they really get off on
in Israel you noticed it right away that
was almost what they would ask every
time because we would do a Q&A all for
comedians come out at the end and let
you know you're usually in some sort of
theater in a synagogue or something like
that you know and and that's their first
question you know what what what what
did you observe that you didn't expect
like that kind of thing and like you
said for a comedian it's an automatic
ten new minutes it's like you know in
five days you have ten new minutes cuz
there's you know you a lot of your jokes
don't work you gotta come up with [ __ ]
that you noticed yeah I don't think I'll
ever do that gig I guess guts uh you
know I guess I'm a little too Johnny
dragstrip variable I don't think but
you're not a dirty comedian no but I
mean like um okay let me let me just lay
a short quick joke on you okay did I
mean come on if this wouldn't work in
Israel you know I'm from Orlando we have
amusement parks right there is amusement
park in Orlando called the holy land
experience and what they've done is
they've recreated ancient Jerusalem at a
highway exit and I have to say the place
is very authentic because the parking
lot is full of Palestinians and they
can't get in I would laugh at that they
would they would let they have a sense
of humor about their country they're not
and you know what I noticed we weren't
really doing shows for people that were
born and bred in Israel they were mostly
American transplants almost all of them
they even crazier I'd be in like you
said Jerusalem or I'd be in some town I
can't even pronounce and I would say I
grew up in Cherry Hill New Jersey and
eight people would clap and I'm like
what they're like we were from there it
was like what and then like I live in
New Rochelle New York now I met somebody
in Israel not only that
ooh new rochelle he grew up on my same
[ __ ] Street I was like what he's like
yeah I lived on a 36 I'm like what i
live at 24 like it was just crazy Wow
and yeah so it was kind of fancy isn't
it that's a upper crust I I wouldn't say
that I know I you mean the people over
there I've never been i just know it's
kind of like the wealthy suburb of
Philadelphia right Oh a cherry I'm
thinking you're talking about Israel
Israel IPPY sorry oh yeah yeah cherry
hill as is known as a very rich Jewish
town which is why the so many people
from cherry hill lived in these cities
in Israel was crazy for you know I
forgot until I got there oh I have a
connection you know even now I could i
get booked at synagogues every once in a
while I don't love performing at them
but it's like every once in a while
they're amazing like like it was in
Israel the last night in Tel Aviv
imagine having all these rules that
you're like trying to work around for
like eight shows and then you hit the
ninth one and they're like you could say
whatever the [ __ ] you want now you could
talk about [ __ ] [ __ ] if you want I
was like really they're like Tel Aviv it
doesn't matter and then you yeah tel
aviv's supposed to be balls out a fun
party city I look when i lived in
amsterdam for five years um a lot of
televisions live in amsterdam and and
that's all i heard was man is just like
fun party 24 hour and and it and i heard
for doing comedy there you don't have to
they they like it falls out no I might
have been the best show I've ever had in
my life seriously um maybe I should just
go to Tel Aviv yeah you would like that
the imagine New York City this is how
this is what i would say Tel Aviv is its
New York City with the like if it was
connected to the Caribbean like you're
literally the sand is butting up against
the buildings you know just like crazy
that you're in this big city eating this
incredible food and all this stuff and
you can you can also eat it on the beach
while you're sitting there like not
normally like in America
if you're sitting on a beach you're
eating some shitty food that costs a lot
you know but there it's like you're
eating this authentic like pita bread
and fallout all these incredible Middle
Eastern food while you're sitting on the
on the sand at this like table that I
can't even explain it but it was and the
water is just like it's if there's no
waves it's just the most perfect Beach
you've ever seen but there are
loudspeakers on the beach cranking up
scary announcements which is a bit i
ended up doing by the middle yeah but by
the middle of the week that was true
your gas mask on yeah literally that was
the joke because they sound it sounds
like you're about to die when they're
yelling in Hebrew and I swear like
you're like relaxing oh my god this is a
perfect moment in my life and yeah I
swear to God then the punch line and
this is true the translation was ladies
and gentlemen the lifeguards are now
going home like I swear to god I'm
thinking tsunami they're up a rocket was
launched right at us which that's
another thing you get you get used to
when I was there I had never been to a
place where you're technically at war
kind of and rockets were launched while
i was there into the country and the
people over there don't even bat an eye
they don't they don't care they feel
like they know they're safe it's weird
Wow but because of that I think makes
them warm warm more loving fun people to
be around because of that I feel that
Americans take for granted that they're
safe and they act like [ __ ] you know
no one over there was an [ __ ] I
didn't see any [ __ ] i did the
edinburgh comedy festival last year in
scotland and i made really good friends
with this comedian he lives in jerusalem
and he's from Philadelphia his name is
yes rail Campbell you ever heard of this
guy he he probably met us when we were
in Tel Aviv a few of the television you
lose an Israelite lives in Jerusalem but
you should have him on your podcast
really really really fascinating guy
really cool dude and he's from Philly
yeah and he did his show they're called
circumcised me he really really fat him
anyway I'll look am I spend my episode
given a plug for another guy but he's a
brilliant beautiful human being yeah and
uh so basically we'll cut to the issue
it's funny because I had this meeting
great meeting accidental meeting with a
guy that you know does a lot of the
advertising for podcasters which is it's
starting to happen the pot these pot our
podcasts they're starting to really
surface and it was funny from talking to
this guy I realized as I'm explaining to
him my podcast and he said he's listened
to a few episodes and I had told him
that I ran a survey about my podcast on
Twitter and my facebook page because I
was thinking of going to this like paper
listen kind of thing and I wanted to see
what the people listening thought and
then there were other questions in the
survey and one person in the survey said
hey why don't you go back to how you
used to talk about your your one problem
with the guests and then you would help
fix the guests a little bit like that I
liked it when you would do that with
every guess and I was like oh I guess I
started that I stopped doing that and
didn't realize it and as I'm talking to
this guy who's in the advertising
business I'm realizing that's that's
what my show is why did I get away from
that and and you know if it helps if
someone can explain what your show is to
somebody to get more people listening oh
this is a guy that has his his listeners
fix him and his his problems are kind of
sometimes out there or sometimes generic
it's your hook that's better than you
know oh it's another podcast for
comedians talking to another green about
comedians yeah now like my podcast I was
because I wanted to do this television
show I wanted to be because i was
traveling around the world and i have
comedian friends all over the world I
wanted to be the Anthony Bourdain of
comedy and I was trying to make a
television show where you know instead
of he checks out food I would check out
comedy scenes I would highlight a
comedian from these different you know
countries around the world
then also does my stuff work in that
country you know I thought that's a
great idea nobody wanted to make this
show me but but how long ago was that uh
it's been a couple years since I pitched
it but my podcast was an extension of
that idea so I interviewed comedians all
over the world in my travels and I had
that guy yes real Campbell on that I was
telling you about but now I live in Los
Angeles and like all these comedians and
Marin has already talked to everybody so
like now my podcast I'm trying to just
go a different way with it and pour out
knowledge nuggets and and things that I
know so I mean you have a easily
definable hook or premise shall we say
of you know fixing jail well thank you
everybody I love see that's an idea what
you just explained sounds like a really
identifiable hooking that I would listen
to um but you know I don't think you
should look at it as Marin uh has
already talked everybody he didn't talk
to everybody about that though what
you're saying he didn't you don't unless
he happen to have some comedian from
Russia on and the guy explained in
detail the comedy scene in Russia I mean
see one I you should go I don't know I'm
telling you I sound like one of those
guys who wrote a book read the chapter 7
in my book III interviewed Owen Benjamin
a couple weeks ago who's a funny comic
and he kind of inspired me in the
interview in a way that we can do these
things that we used to try as comedians
to turn into something the industry
would want to make a TV show about and
now its flipped where it's like no this
is that I'm doing the thing right now
like I don't need you to make a show
about it like you don't need to do a
show about you being the Anthony
Bourdain a comedy you don't need a
network to make it like you're that
you're going to these places like Owen
Benjamin literally film [ __ ] you gotta
what he has this documentary on his
website he just was films filming [ __ ]
with this iphone and he turned it into a
documentary and you watch it you go this
looks good
like this looks like a documentary and
if you do it the right way you can do
things for almost nothing you now I'm
giving you advice you know I'm fixing it
no I made I may be travel videos yeah
but you get the world I mean I've made
you know little pilot versions of it and
many versions of it made great clips on
Cambodia Vietnam Malaysia everywhere
Ireland I've seen some of them on
youtube I remember watching it's coming
to me I remember watching this because I
am fascinated by different places and so
so is there a way for you to make some
sort of uh I don't know make that show
without it being on television being
somehow like a documentary or something
like that like that you would see on
Netflix uh yeah I um I mean here's my
pitch for you I got it I just got it
because I'm noticing a new you probably
noticed this too comedians now aren't
just doing comedy specials especially
when you see them on netflix I'm
noticing a lot of them are documentary /
1 hour specials yeah like Todd Barry did
that road tour thing or not wrote or
that's David tell Todd that was David
tells documentary / comedy did all these
different gigs and then Todd Barry did
the all a crowd work thing and it you
know it showed him in his house and all
that kind of stuff and then TIG Notaro
did something where she's doing comedy
and all these like people's living rooms
and [ __ ] all over the country and that
was on netflix like that sounds like a
great one hour special with you in all
these different countries talking to all
these different people and then we see
you perform it in all these different
countries is anyone no one's really no
one's done a special where they're in
different countries I mean Chris Rock
did different states in was just wearing
a different outfit but you're going to
other countries I would watch that yeah
well I mean I need I need to get I need
someone to get behind it because I was
filming it myself all these years I
called it extended arm productions yeah
I bye but a yeah you're like it's like
you're doing selfies in every country
how many hours of footage do you have
from all these countries oh god I've got
I got thousands of hours of footage of
stuff and interviews I've filmed with
comedians and stuff that I've shot all
over the world and me and on a
high-definition camera of filmed yeah I
see you you probably with the right
sit-down interviews that look pretty
high-end and those don't cost a lot you
could probably cut them together with
what you have in you and you have a film
you know look look what look what
Jeffrey Ross did is is all low end when
he went to perform for the troops it was
all like like you're saying with the
camera and that that was on Showtime and
everything I mean he did well with that
I don't know I didn't see it but I'll go
check it out I think you fixed me I
don't know if that's your dream project
but so my issue and you can maybe give
me advice with this because you're a
pretty relaxed guy and I with the
medication have been really relaxed but
I started taking adderall for a TD on
top of this anti-anxiety medication
right arm took a long series of tests
with Donna making sex with your wife I
am having this what would that what is
uh it's it's a bed wetter he's I was a
bed wetter if that means anything is our
bed wetters they're getting bullied at
school what's the see your relax people
they can never understand someone who's
just born with anxiety like what can
make you get really be that struck me as
very confident guy and you know
good-looking guy muscular you're not
like you know neurotic and weird-shaped
head or but you know they used to say
that about Nick DiPaolo they never
understood why he would get so mad they
were like he's got a model girlfriend
he's a handsome guy and he's yelling at
people it's like if you have oh I
explain and it just happened the main
issue that I want to talk about today is
i don't know if it's the adderall if i'm
drinking coffee mixed with adderall I
thought I had the anxiety gone and then
all of a sudden this past weekend here
in New York we got like over 25 inches
of snow and I i bought a snow blower
this is this is where it all went down i
buy that I for years I've wanted a snow
blower finally I said [ __ ] it I'm not
shoveling anymore I'm not hiring
somebody to shovel I'm getting a snow
blower I bought it I felt good I
couldn't wait to use it I realize you
got to put oil in the snow blower you
can't just put the gas in I'm such an
idiot there's like a hole for the oil on
an angle at the bottom of the snow
blower it doesn't come with the oil when
you buy it no you gotta you buy a
separate little thing they give you the
little bottle are you expect it's going
to have all the proper fluids what's the
difference in a snow blower exactly it
didn't I have to put the oil in I don't
have a funnel and there's snow all over
I don't go by a funnel I start twisting
this piece of plastic that I found in
the trash trying to shove it in the hole
so I can pour the oil down I cut my
finger and now I'm pouring oil into an
open cut on my finger and it it kills
I'm losing my mind thank God I'm in the
garage back in the days I used to lose
my mind out loud in front of neighbors
and like they would be afraid of me so
I'm Lou I'm literally like it's like I'm
a car that's overheating in my I'm in my
garage I'm like oh like the it's not
coming out but it's just internalizing
and I'm literally like making a fist and
veins are blown out on my forehead and I
think I go that's what it was I go in
side to get a ladder from my wife
because I need to get to this higher
shelf in our garage where our shovel is
because I think I might need a shovel
for a couple spots she comes to the door
and she didn't even say anything and I
just went flat like I just yelled in her
face she got scared because I had done
it like two days earlier and she just
walked away from me and I was like I
just scared my wife hates when I do this
she
can't handle it I didn't grow up with a
or my wife didn't grow up with anybody
like me and how I get when I just lose
my [ __ ] and I go back to the snowblower
and I realize there's like an easy fix
all I have to do is lift the snow blower
up a little bit in the back and now the
holes not on an angle it's just straight
up and I just pour you know the oil in
and it was easy yeah it was it was easy
and I'm doing this in front of my kids
and I'm like what the [ __ ] and I said to
my wife I got oh I need the up to celexa
medication that I take for anxiety do I
need to not drink coffee in the morning
when I take the you know adderall is
speed I don't have ever taken speed in
your life not um government-sanctioned
like what though like just regular was
cranked something the people you're like
I feel like you're a guy that maybe I've
tried a lot of drugs when i was living
in new york I 98 99 I had a lot of money
and was hanging out with Mitch Hedberg a
lot and we we did a little bit of
cocaine oh yeah now is cocaine something
that would ever make you yell could it
ever get on man I mean that shit's the
worst um you know it makes you retreat
from people it makes you you know lick
your lips a lot and it makes you nervous
and then and and for writing jokes it
was the worst it was um you know uh
Hedberg would have new material all the
time which was blew me away because like
I thought it was the least creative drug
ever and the noise heard about prior
felt very invincible on cocaine for him
prior for prior cocaine like fuel this
comedy gave him confidence gave him
jokes um I you know that's why I didn't
stick with it he had it ever given me
one joke i I've heard I've heard more of
your experience on cocaine than the
Richer prior experience more comedians
say no no this is bad let's thing in the
world for comedy yeah yeah screws up
your timing
makes you feel nervous on stage yeah now
it goes against everything that you've
earned as you know through practice and
perseverance and was there aware off to
it like when it wore off you were like
you would like like be pissed off or
anything like that when it would wear
off and yeah I mean like a lot of drugs
just make you feel like [ __ ] like a
loser the next day you know like why did
I do that I was like talking two idiots
until five in the morning about nothing
you know are there any drugs that don't
do that that you wake up and you go feel
good I feel fine um i have had a few
mushroom experiences where I felt um you
know I had gained some secret answer to
the universe but my wife why should tell
you you know I was partying so hard when
I lived in New York City I actually
moved to Amsterdam to bring it down a
notch uh just which is actually true and
Dutch people my wife is from Holland and
and she absolutely hates drugs of any
kind and weed I stopped drinking two
years ago and I stopped smoking
cigarettes nine months ago oh wow so
I've had a pretty big transformation in
the last few years stop drinking
completely yeah and no sister I was in
Philadelphia um I blacked out in a bar
and fell off of a barstool and hit a
tile floor I got six stitches on my
forehead right here it's looking better
now the first year it looked like I had
a vagina but um and that was your
wake-up call and that was my wake-up
call yeah I was like I just saw so much
ugliness in the mirror the next day I
had these Frankenstein stitches and I
had a black eye and and then the last
few years I I was starting to you know
get that fat white guy alcoholic face
you know that puffy bloated face right
and you know I was always kind of a
decent looking guy and and then I I'm
gonna busted my head open um I didn't
have any assurance in any insurance it
cost me four thousand dollars and but
even before I got the bill I decided
just the next day I was like I was not
put on this earth to be a drunk you know
I was put here to do great things so um
and I didn't go to any AAA meetings I
just yeah I don't know i mean some
people hit their head and they they
automatically speak French you've heard
the stories right I my head and hey I no
longer wanted to drink alcohol ever met
in my life really that was probably like
you like hitting somebody while drunk
driving you know like that just went oh
whoa I'm done did you and your wife knew
you when you were drinking yeah and um
we argue considerably less since I
stepped especially since she doesn't at
all yeah well she'll have a glass of
wine like once every month or two now
you're not one of those guys that thinks
he could still maybe have one glass of
wine here and there you don't you know
not to dabble no desire and you know I I
really know a lot about wine I lived
with a Frenchwoman years ago we taught
me all about wine I lived in Europe I
really love wine and um you know I enjoy
picking out bottles for my wife but um I
I just don't drink it you know that's
great that's great and she was probably
like she probably knew like from the
moment she met you if he can just not
drink he's the greatest guy there's this
one thing she ever suggested yeah she
still finds reasons to be if no I mean
did she ever suggest the not drinking
when you were drinking like oh no never
no no no and one thing I found
attractive about her was her ability to
drink heavily so she used to UM she used
to drink right with me okay see might
see I'm at this stage where
our I worry about that sometimes with me
because of the adderall that I take that
rock Reno gets me focused especially
like where it comes becomes tricky is if
I'm doing a podcast or somebody else's
podcasts at like eight or nine o'clock
at night I would I want to be on the
drug that helps my focus right cool yeah
yeah yeah yeah so what happens is is
when you take this drug adderall you
take it at eight o'clock now at twelve
o'clock you're still on it in your brain
and you can't go to sleep because you're
up from the adderall so I would have a
couple of glasses of wine or I'd pour a
couple glasses of bourbon or I have a
few beers and like you know my wife grew
up with an alcoholic father so it lights
her up if she I know if she came down a
couple of the nights like when she's
sleeping and I'm like drinking something
out of a bottle not a glass you know she
would she would get really upset and I I
I don't you know i'm lucky i don't have
the genes of the alcoholic no one in my
family's and it's you know an alcoholic
so I never liked drinking eight drinks
or anything but um I don't like that
it's every day and it's a few drinks and
then I have it or I can't go to sleep
well my dad was um he always had a
cocktail in his hand and he was the life
of the party and I never saw anything
wrong with it and my dad was really
funny and I always associated comedy
with oh man you're the leader of the
party you know you're the comedian so I
always associated the two together and
the fact that we get free drinks
everywhere we perform I also looked at
it as part of my payment like oh my god
if I'm not drinking ten beverages a
night i'm not getting part of my pay and
I guess that's maturity you know I mean
I've been doing comedy for 32 years now
and you know I've i went from young
inexperienced guy to like you know a
successful guy and then you know now
veteran and and the outer minutes are
interesting the dynamic you know you're
in the clubs and there was some I was at
the improv last week and there was some
young comedian this girl and she was
plastered and she thought she was being
witty to me talking to me and she was
just like such an idiot and then also
it's really powerful not to drink
because everyone gives away all of their
secrets you're talking to somebody and
they have no ideas like you know and my
password from a name I'm birthday and
there's a stuffy that's exactly what my
wife says she's because that's what it
is I i connect it with if you eat
Chinese food and your wife doesn't eat
Chinese food she thinks your breath
stinks but if you both ate Chinese food
no one's breath stinks so like if she's
sober and I had two drinks even though
it's just two drinks I'm an idiot
compared to her so she and it's not the
guy that she fell in love with it's the
to drink version of the guy it's not
that guy anymore like I get it why my
wife would be turned off when I have a
few drinks to remember and like my wife
is really amazing I know it's a
photographer yeah um and you know she
traveled with me we've been together for
seven years and she traveled with me all
over the world you know so every week
we're going to a different city and you
know i'm looking for jokes she's taken
photos and stuff and we've had long
conversations about this and the thing
you have to remember about your wife
like my wife is your wife always wants
you to be the smartest person in the
room you know that's a good night the
drunk idiot saying something
inappropriate yeah well I'm never the
smartest person in the world in the room
she had she my wife as a PhD and is very
intellectual and ever been able to take
a compliment that's what I like my no
but I'm know I'm thinking the funny here
is is no I think in the comedic angle
instantly but because of her family
being so smart her mom and dad are super
intelligent so is my wife and her two
sisters so why would I want to make
myself even stupider
I'm already I'm already fighting to try
to be kind of on their level and you're
gonna drink like what are you an idiot
you shouldn't be drinking no you should
be reading in a corner with a
highlighter you know uh yeah I almost
think I have to pull an alcoholic move
and not have it in my house when I don't
have it in my house I don't drink but I
end up going buying it I have it and
then when it's here I want it's like you
like I don't want to waste it you're
gonna angle you gonna show me you got
like a case of wine right next to you no
prescription for you it is not alcoholic
beer Oh a book a 12-step book seneca
seneca with a Seneca Seneca was a
philosopher during the Roman period and
uh he was a stoic and there's a few
thing you reminded me when we were
talking about anger before so Seneca
said that drinking alcohol was
self-induced insanity that II why would
you make yourself insane to the memory I
mean I read this [ __ ] when I was still
drinking you know but he was a stoic and
the Stoics believed that anger was a
sign of weakness that you should you
should have enough self-control not to
be angered by stupid people or things
you know uh the dude you know there's
there's there's not too much too many
books and they're all very thin it so
you could just google seneca quotes and
and learn a lot but what's his most
famous quote do you know it the one off
the top of my head is it drinking was
self-induced anger um that is so true
though that is yeah so I'm gonna I'll
try reading those books I mean I i love
when people prescribes just just google
some quotes okay I don't do that now I
want to ask you really quick before we
and we'll wrap will wrap up with the
interview in this way because it seems
like you've beaten the alcohol and it's
kind of got you to a really good place
and you see
really happy but like I said you you've
always seemed happy to me is it is there
anything yeah yeah yeah and is there
anything that you still struggle with
anything it could be like your anything
it doesn't have to be mental it could be
something in your house anything yeah I
mean I did have a few difficult years um
hi apparently though do you feel like is
there anything currently happening well
I mean I have to tell you you and my
father was killed by a drunk driver in
2009 oh and it was a rich guy who got
off with just a light probation so I was
angry about that uh and then my my
little sister died of breast cancer in
2011 oh and then I was angry at God
after that I can see that so I've always
been a really happy guy and you know
never bitter and just really enjoyed
life and my life is a comedian but for a
couple years after that I had a lot of
anger and it now I'm out of it I really
I feel great again and the fact that I'm
not drinking it's just you know you see
so many people and comedians just
getting consumed by anger and that's why
I brought up the thing about Seneca that
the soap stoics looked at anger as as
like a weakness that you should really
just control yourself you know you cut
yourself on a snow blower I mean [ __ ] it
by another one by one you know I don't
know but uh you know my frustrations are
uh you know i'm i'm i'm very doing very
well these days i'm happy to have a nest
with my wife after traveling for so long
I've been working on a book for the last
few years about my life travel in the
world as comedian and so I mean my
frustrations are just that you know I
wish it was already done right you know
I still have a few more chapters to
write and then you got to go back and
polish up your first draft kind of stuff
but I mean I you know I've got a great
reputation as a comedian and I i can do
gigs all over the world I don't have too
much that um you know it's not muffins
weighing you down right now I can see it
in your face yes I had some I had a UH
got a tough stretch difficult couple of
years you know well I've always known
you're not you're not thinking about uh
right and gilkes when you're thinking
about punching people out you know what
I'm saying yeah well I'd I have noticed
I have noticed that when when we do have
the unfortunate things of losing
somebody in your life that was close
there's something about it whenever it
happens that it's this horrendously bad
thing but it opens something up in your
brain usually you know especially you go
little life is short that always opens
up like okay I'm gonna love more people
because life is short i mean um i have
my cousin I I had a first cousin who
died last week and I didn't I didn't
even know him I think I'd met him twice
in my life and I know his brothers a
little bit and I got a call and it like
jarred me even though it was a cuz I
don't even know him but it more jarred
me because I was like [ __ ] I didn't know
him I was like he's not I don't know I
didn't know him why didn't I know him
you know like so it opened that side of
me you know and and and it made me you
know want to be with my wife from want
to be with my kids so that it does
something you know so it seems like your
anger pulled away and now you're at that
place where you're like you're like okay
let's let's really build what I do have
right yeah I mean it makes you
appreciate not be in dealing with
tragedies I think that's the toughest
thing about being a comedian is when you
have [ __ ] going on in your life like a
heartbreak with a relationship or like
someone close to you that you love dies
to you know still go on stage I mean it
did feel good to put my brain on a shelf
during the grief and sorrow period but
I'm happy it's behind me yeah that's
great that's great so uh you what would
you like the plug on the fixing Joe
podcast it sounds like you're you will
you're writing a book and you have your
podcast which is called Tom Rhodes radio
Tom Rhodes radio are you on all things
comedy also yeah alright yeah ok we're
both over there and I've been another
good thing about finally having a house
is I can be more creative you know the
you know it was great traveling but
every week would go to a different city
and then you know new group of comedian
friends to hang out with and and all
this stuff I've been making these videos
I've been putting them out once a week
called knowledge nuggets and they're
just you know I love to read and I'm
just full of like different knowledge so
they're only like two minutes long I'll
give you an example a Shakespeare so
these are like the knowledge Nuggets
I've been doing making these videos and
Shakespeare's competition when
Shakespeare was first putting on these
classic works of English literature at
the Globe Theatre in London his primary
competition at the other theaters around
the globe theatre where shows were live
animals fought to the death and one of
the most popular ones was a show where
they would take a monkey and put it on
top of a horse in a theater and then
they would take like five dogs that
haven't eaten in a week and let him
loose and the dogs would claw the horse
to death trying to get at the monkey and
the show wasn't over until the monkey
was dead so think about that you know
you think you got like difficulties in
show business you know at least we don't
have to compete with you know live
animals fighting to the death and and
you know it must have been very
difficult to remove monkey blood and
monkey brain from your 15th century
English ruffled clothing
so like making some really I'm really
enjoying um making these videos you know
my films him and um she had it's my
podcast and stuff so you know we're a
good little unit that sounds like it
well mom and pop is dying to meet your
wife someday yeah in Philadelphia man I
uh you know one on her sat on I I kind
of get this smile on my face now
whenever I hear the word Philadelphia or
see like a a sports team because my life
was forever changed when I busted my
head open in Philadelphia uh I really
consider that one of the greatest things
that ever happened to me in my life
that's crazy how you know I just like
stopped drinking instantly events I read
michael j fox as memoir years ago and he
actually thanks parkinson's disease he
thinks it was life-changing he said I
was an [ __ ] before I had this Wow he
said the first thing to go when you have
Parkinson's is your vanity he goes if
you give a [ __ ] about the way you look
and you have parkinson's disease it's
gonna be a cruel rest of your life it's
like I could give a [ __ ] anymore about
that that's not important and it's
pretty amazing and I love life moments
where a negative turns into a positive
you know dude thanks so much and where
can they get the videos though they on
your website yeah my my utah my website
is Tom Rhodes net but my youtube channel
um is called king of haha or you could
just type in Tom Rhodes on it pops up um
but yeah my my youtube channel I put out
the knowledge nugget videos once a week
I put up an episode of my podcast once a
week I think it's never been a better
time to be a comedian that's good you
you don't need suits at networks to
approve anything that you're making and
its really like the Golden Age
Renaissance for stand-up comedy you know
thankfully the world is so [ __ ] up now
that people really need laughter and
everything but if you're a creative
person you know you can do anything now
it's really great yeah I look at Twitter
as it's like your network it's like okay
here you go I'm sure here's something I
want to show you like tweet tweet me
your newest video and I'll retweet it or
all yeah I guess that's how you do it I
would retain it to all my Twitter people
this is about Thomas Edison okay send it
over I love [ __ ] like this because it's
like a funny way if I can learn through
funny I always know it like my wife that
will be amazed sometimes at the [ __ ] i
know and i'm like i learned that because
i heard a dennis miller to a joke about
moment shots like it's like weird how I
just know it from a comedy thing and i
love it i love comedy where you learn
stuff ah Thomas Edison invented the
light bulb but he didn't want to make
money selling light bulbs he wanted to
make money selling electricity and his
main competition was from George
Westinghouse so there was only about a
dozen power stations in the Northeast
United States him Westinghouse and
Edison making these things so at the
same time people thought that the
hanging capital punishment was cruel and
inhumane so people thought that
electrocuting people to death might be a
nicer way to murder people in the United
States Edison was vehemently against
capital punishment but he secretly
funded the development of the electric
chair using Westinghouse electricity
because he wanted it to be in the minds
of Americans that Westinghouse
electricity will kill you and Edison put
on demonstrations with the electric
chair where he murdered dogs horses and
once in Coney Island New York he
electrocuted a circus elephant named
Topsy to death now kind of a you know
you know an evil twisted thing to do but
like genius marketing know that just so
he could get an upper hand in in
business isn't that amazing so those are
like maybe I should make a TV show out
of knowledge nuggets well it sounds like
a history show history channel show
waiting to happen like you and Colin
Quinn together
comedic lee taking us teaching us about
history is a classic info inglot write
the book i will you don't need them
that's right hey joe i miss you man it's
great to see I should come to New York
more often yeah you should I want to do
your podcast that's not love love to
have you and you ever come to do it do
you have six you can't do it this way oh
yeah that great you it this way i could
actually what am I saying we have
acknowledged even do me one yeah New
York yeah I would love to do your
podcast look let's make a date I would
love to have you on do you want to make
the date now or you want to email you
want to email me or do you want to make
the date now I don't look like a guy
that has this calendar in his brain I do
that Lee really you know you know when
you want to do it yeah februari I'm
pretty slammed let's shoot for cuz now
what january's over now do you have a
certain day you do it on no I mean I put
them out on Tuesday but i can record
them anytime oh okay so all right we'll
do it in March okay oh yeah or there's a
couple days in February we can do it oh
let's we'll pick a date okay definitely
I would love to do it and I go listen to
Tom Rhodes us stuff and watch these
videos these little uh when I snuggie
knowledge nuggets with Tom Rhodes I love
it ah dude great talking to you angry
talking you to jail it makes me realize
you know how much farther I'm past a
black period in my life talking to you
you fixed me man you were already I
could do qu showed up fixed alright dude
a good talking here I'll stick later
[ __ ] love that guy what a [ __ ]
good guy always loved Tom Rhodes always
had his seemed like he had his head
screwed on the way I wanted it screwed
on I think you could hear it in the
interview go check out all this stuff
Tom Rhodes rh o de esas how he spells
his last name rh
des Tom Rhodes one of my favorites
hilarious comedian and one of those
dudes would be fun to hang out with them
it was a lot intelligent man as we said
at the beginning of the podcast still
plug in my februari 13th date love to
have you go to joe Matarese calm buy
tickets to that wonderful theater called
the ritz theater in haddon township new
jersey today before Valentine's Day
still some tickets left not a lot still
some okay so trying to figure out who's
the opener who's it gonna be who is it
gonna be I don't know I don't know I
hope by me and Tom trying to fix
ourselves we help fix you guys that
we're listening I hope our advice
transferred is that the right word into
your lives I hope you feel a little
better now after listening to this
podcast I love my wife I love my kids
and keep downloading the podcast
everybody and follow us on twitter i'm
at be joe Matarese send me a little
donation I'd appreciate that joe
Matarese calm click on the donate button
and you get some free merch at all your
donations it's all explained there on my
website okay everybody you have a great
rest of your week a tight oh yeah I'm
only doing one a week now did I tell you
that one a week the two a week I don't
know just didn't feel right we're doing
one a week a lot more to explain but
keep listening everybody take it easy
love you guys
you